this is essential protective equipment
for NHS workers and it's running out
those on the front line in the fight
against coronavirus now facing the
prospect of doing it without proper
protection the government promised an
extra 84 tonnes of PPE to be delivered
from Turkey yesterday it didn't happen
it didn't happen today either with
supplies of medical gowns running
particularly short public health England
advising doctors to make do with
alternatives but senior medics say
that's not good enough now for the first
time the guidance has changed based on
availability of equipment and there's no
evidence to say that it offers the same
amount of protection as as previously
and so staff are going in working on the
front line treating patients and
potentially putting their own health at
risk and if not their own lives in some
situations ministers acutely aware these
shortages are upsetting not just NHS
staff but the public too we are working
hard to get the PPE our frontline NHS
and social care staff need we're working
to resolve the Turkish shipment of PPE
as soon as possible and we are of course
continuing to pursue every possible
option for PPE procurement some of the
bodies representing medics are deeply
concerned do you acknowledge that NHS
staff are potentially risking their own
safety to look after patients the
guidance remains exactly the same in
exceptional circumstances advice has
been produced jointly with the NHS about
how to be safe in circumstances where
supplies may be at risk can you
understand why some NHS workers might
feel if they go to work and they haven't
got the equipment they just can't stay
in that environment I understand
people's anxieties on the frontline
where they're in a very uncertain
situation but I would stress again that
the advice has been put out precisely to
give them some information in those kind
of circumstances the NHS pressure
immediate but economic pressure build
into the
economic and indeed health damage of
this lockdown is so severe that we've
got to put everything in place now all
the preparedness we we need in order to
make sure we can ease the lockdown as
much as possible while still being
responsible about the spread of the
disease the current prime minister still
recovering at his checkers country
retreat not officially back at work but
now getting daily briefings the coming
days will be all about managing the
health crisis but the risk of a
deepening economic crisis grows the
longer the lockdown goes on all the
choices difficult now bath Rigby Sky
News Westminster